who benefits from consumer relief
payouts Citigroup has agreed to pay
seven billion dollars to settle
government claims over fraudulent
activity in the mortgage security market
in 2006 and 2007 conduct that Attorney
General Eric Holder describes as
egregious late last year JPMorgan
settled similar allegations for 13
billion dollars with four billion
earmarked for consumer relief two and a
half billion of this latest Citigroup
fine will fund similar efforts the
beneficiaries will include underwater
homeowners will be able to modify their
existing loans distressed borrowers will
get help with refinancing home buyers
will be eligible for assistance with
down payments and closing costs and
community focused organizations will
receive donations to help with
redevelopment and affordable housing
programs the main aim of course is to
keep citigroup borrowers in their homes
the precedent for both these consumer
relief programs is a 25 billion dollar
mortgage-related settlement between the
federal government 49 states and five
major banks including JPMorgan and
Citigroup just a year after that deal
was struck in 2012 the five banks
reported to government monitors that
more than 640,000 borrowers at each
enjoyed benefits totaling around $80,000
the Department of Justice says these
fines an attempt to hold institutions
accountable but they should also offer
some relief to those whose lives have
been negatively affected by Wall Street